do you know that being a Jets fan
actually makes me understand people
meaning in real life I have this almost
borderline delusion although I know it's
fully grounded in practicality optimism
I have no Envy I have no jealousy I have
no anger I have no Darkness I really
don't it's kind of scary it's a
blessing but in football I have all that
I'm jealous of patriot banss I'm sad
that we didn't get Patrick Mahomes when
we could have drafted him and it's all
this resem it's 40 Years of pain right
and it lashes out I'm like really scared
somebody's going to film me at a Jets
game one day it's going to ruin the
whole the whole nice of it just
finished what the just happened I'm
not nice and the people are listening
that I'm really not there's like some
inside jokes with my friends like I once
yelled at this 80-year-old man it was
really inappropriate like I yell at kids
I'm on tilt I feel that pain I feel that
anger Taylor Swift was sitting right
above me at the Jets Chiefs game I was
mad at that
box